the czech republic has expelled 18
russian diplomats who it says are
military spies
the russian embassy staffers staffers
pardon me
are being kicked out after czech
officials said they found clear
evidence that moscow operatives were
involved in deadly explosions
at an ammunition depot in 2014.
the blast that claimed two lives a
military ammunitions warehouse in the
east of the czech republic
explodes in october 2014 causing
widespread damage
two months later another similar
explosion
seven years on the czech government says
it's found a link between
the explosions and russian secret
services
based on clear evidence obtained during
the investigation
conducted by our security services i can
see there is
well-grounded suspicion about the
involvement of officers of the russian
intelligence service
gru
and these are the key suspects believed
to have been in the country at the time
of the blast
both men are also wanted in the uk in
connection with the 2018 poisoning of
sergey skripal
a former russian spy and 18 russian
embassy staffers accused of being
military spies now have 48 hours to
leave the country
moscow has denied involvement and says
there will be diplomatic consequences
very sorry that the czech russian
relationship will suffer like this
however as the prime minister has said
the czech republic
needs to react
czech officials are now considering
excluding russian corporations
from an upcoming bid to build new
reactors at the dukovani
nuclear power plant choosing a
contractor for the build has become a
symbol of geopolitical allegiance for
the czech republic
will lay out its grievances at a meeting
of eu foreign ministers on monday
another sign of growing international
anger at russia's actions abroad
you